Let's go next to our caller from the eight
one six area code. Who's calling today from
eight one six?
Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Even mainstream. I'm 18 years old and I don't
necessarily fit the mold of a typical progressive.
I'm actually a moderate. And I wanted to hear
your thought process on this. We talk about
Bernie Sanders inability to win over black
voters like myself and more moderate voters,
right?
Yes. So what we saw on the South was second
time. And he has to win over black voters.
The older girls.
So if you believe that black voters and I
don't know this for sure. But if you believe
that black voters are an important person
in the Democratic electorate, then is it true
that even though Biden is no progressive,
he is he has her base then Bernie does, which
was one of the arguments of Bernie's about
why you should vote for him, the city, skip,
skip all sorts of voters and and build this
giant tent of the electorate in order to defeat
Donald Trump in the fall.
Well, I don't. I mean, listen, from a personal
standpoint, of course, I think black voters
are important as. I mean, listen, I don't
want to write off any portion of the electorate.
Every portion of the electorate is important.
But I don't think we need to speculate about,
you know, does Biden have a bigger base by
virtue of having more black support? Biden
got way more votes in the primaries. So from
the perspective of the Democratic primary,
even before Bernie dropped out, Biden was
winning by around one point eight one point
nine million votes. So, I mean, Biden won
because he had more people supporting him.
I I guess I don't need I don't feel the need
to hypothesize about whether it's specifically
because of black black voters. Trump But Biden
had way more way more voters in the primary
when it comes to Biden versus Trump. It looks
like about 92 percent of black voters right
now are supporting Biden. And we can slice
and dice it in other ways. But you're there's
no question that Biden had more support. That's
why he won the primary.
Yeah, I just I wanted to understand that because,
you know, I talked to some people and I was
told that, you know, if you look at the primary
where we reached the last Super Tuesday before
Bernie dropped out. Watching your videos and
you talked about how you know.
Oh, my God. Okay. I'm going to have to let
you go. You it looks like you just cut out
there.